so for the twelfth day of Christmas we
thought we'd have an unboxing so the
video is not about the cardboard though
the chemistry of cardboard is quite
interesting but let's see what's inside
we have another present from our fan
Nagisa Noah in Japan it's the fourth
version of his periodic table clock and
you can see it has a really beautiful
spiral going round and round with all
the elements including flora viim
livermorium really up to date it's a
periodic table clock which will join all
the other periodic table clocks in my
office how many of you got now I've
already got four here what we have is a
really nice demonstration of the
periodic table and we also have
something that summarizes one person's
passion for the periodic table have fans
passion and it's a passion that all of
us making periodic videos those that
watching it share chemistry is a
fantastic subject it's really exciting
even the most boring things like a burnt
piece of wood has chemical secrets
inside it so for day 12 we have periodic
table clock Sophia's sodium tile osmium
and thorium periodic table thanks to the
charge beam from our new lab
from a fan anthracite from pennsylvania
guitar plectrum the glows for drinking
vessels three chemical badges two
periodic table bed covers and one piece
of no Taric acid from a Swiss wine berry
thank you for watching our 12 days of
Christmas thank you to everyone who sent
us these presents thank you to everybody
who sent us emails sent us pictures sent
us comments we're looking forward to
sharing lots of chemistry with you
in 2016
you